[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
the manhunt now over in georgia the
triple shooting that left a golf pro
dead
and two more bodies found bound with
tape in the back of a truck
but with the suspect in custody our
investigators will continue to work the
case to its completion
body cam video capturing the moment
officers in kentucky
rescue a six-year-old girl from
kidnapping
and why chad dabell is not being charged
in the murder of charles vallo
in the latest twists in the doomsday
saga plus contentious testimony from a
defense expert in bones
his opinion on the damage of 13 year old
dylan redwine's body
and what caused it i don't have any idea
what animals do with backpacks
and gruesome testimony from robert durst
trial the millionaire explaining why he
chopped up
his neighbor's body i did not kill
morris black
i did what i did law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
grizzly new details in a triple shooting
in georgia after a golf pro was found
dead on the golf course and the bodies
of two people were found
in the back of a pickup truck police say
their suspect is now behind bars
the lone shooter who's now been
identified
as brian anthony rhoden
he has been charged for the murders of
eugene seiler
paul pearson and henry valdez
police in georgia are announcing the
arrest of the suspect in a triple
homicide
after the bodies of three people were
discovered on a golf course
rhoden is facing three counts of murder
three counts of aggravated assault and
two counts of kidnapping
we literally had detectives that have
worked around the clock
and some have literally slept in their
offices since
july 3rd jail records show rhoden was
arrested early the morning
following the shooting in a county
nearby the charges
dui false identification and acquiring a
license plate to conceal the
identification of a vehicle
rodent bounded out two days later police
are not commenting about what
information they knew
and when his night came up
within uh within a few days of the
investigation
the chief would not comment on a
possible motive or chain of events that
led up to the kidnapping
roden allegedly driving onto the golf
course with two bodies
and shooting golf pro gene siller in a
newly released arrest warrant
investigators say roden bound the hands
legs and mouths
of valdez and pearson with tape i think
i would say that
discovery of all individuals who were
deceased were was made
in a pretty rapid time frame
joining us today is former federal
prosecutor nima romani and terry austin
you know as more and more information
comes out
we get a better picture of the alleged
crime what do you think is next in the
investigation of this triple homicide
brian next is to figure out why rhoden
did it we know he did it
but it's just really fascinating here
you got two victims
two of which have nothing to do with
this golf course they're not members of
the country club
they're obviously probably killed before
their vehicle stolen driven on the golf
course
the third poor victim did work for the
golf course and
happened to stumble upon this individual
rodent having killed two people and he
was victimized as well
so and then really that that what long
crime first reported
and you know credit to them that rhoden
was arrested that evening for a dui and
a number of traffic violations why he
was let go he
clearly wasn't a suspect at the time but
certainly days later police were able to
connect the dots
and now they need to connect everything
to put him away for murder
of three individuals yeah so many
questions especially when you talk about
the
victims here of someone in their 40s in
their 60s different states different
cities
terry let's jump into the next question
it's a triple homicide do you think the
death penalty could
or even should be on the table i
definitely think it could be on the
table brian because this took place in
georgia and we know that georgia
has the death penalty and they actually
do use the death penalty
and you have to have certain aggravating
factors like was this a heinous crime
and yes it was i mean we know that at
least two of the victims
had their hands bound and that is really
a horrendous crime
and it's also multiple deaths so that's
another reason that
they could if they chose to impose the
death penalty so we'll see what happens
absolutely multiple deaths and also the
nature probably we get to eventually
learn it of the first two deaths
may add to that calculus as to whether
or not the death penalty will be added
thank you both
turning now to a major update in the
doomsday cult deal saga
prosecutors in arizona say chad day bell
will not face charges
in another murder linked to the couple
chad dabel and his wife laurie are
currently in custody in idaho
on charges connected to the murders of
lori's two kids seven-year-old j.j vallo
and 16-year-old tylie ryan and the
murder of chad's wife
tammy but laurie's also now facing
charges in the murder of her fourth
husband
charles valo valor was shot and killed
by lori's brother alex cox
who is now deceased in a letter from the
maricopa county attorney to chandler
arizona police
prosecutors say they will not be
charging chad as well because there is
no
reasonable likelihood of conviction
police have previously said that chad
and laurie believe valo
had to die for them to fulfill the
religious prophecy that included
preparing for the end of the world all
right terry you've been watching this
since day one did you see this coming
that chad dabo
wouldn't be charged and why well you
know i think that the prosecution
doesn't have enough evidence and i think
it's a reasonable
action on their part there is no
communication between
chad and laurie about the death of
charles valo
and you need something to bring the
charges and you absolutely need
something to make the charges stick so
if they had telephone logs
or if they had an eyewitness and we know
for a fact that
chad was not there he wasn't present so
i think it's the right decision i don't
know if i anticipated it
but i do think it makes sense since they
weren't able to find
additional evidence to bring chad into
the whole series of events that led up
to charles balo's death
all right so you know my little public
defender gears are kind of turning
around in my head
i can see this definitely hurting uh
lori's other cases when she's found
competent
but could chad somehow turn these facts
that he isn't charged here to his
advantage
brian i agree with terry on this one and
chad's only defense in this case
is that laurie did it the bodies are
buried in his backyard so
we know there's going to be finger
pointing there's already been motions to
sever these trials
chad is going to go first because of
lori's competence issues as you raise
and really the only defense here is that
laurie did it and i didn't know that she
did it so
the fact that she's now involved in
another murder and he's not
does help the defense but still i don't
think this is a very strong
defense case the prosecution took their
time but this is more or less
bulletproof and i expect them both to be
convicted
yeah i think chad's definitely going to
use what i call the shaggy defense it
wasn't me
but a lot of evidence pointing towards
him we'll see how that plays out
and to other top legal news the father
of britney spears
fears growing public criticism against
him and is making it known to the court
in documents jamie spares says he is
quote very concerned
about the dangerous rhetoric surrounding
his daughter's conservatorship
the pop icon made international
headlines last month when she testified
calling the court mandated arrangement
abusive jamie spears is now asking the
court
to deny a request by jody montgomery the
current conservator
of the estate she's asking that britney
spears's money pay for her 24 7 security
a hearing in the conservatorship is
scheduled for next week
r kelly's request to push back his trial
date was granted in a hearing on
thursday
judge ann donnelly set a trial date for
august 18th nine days later than the
previous date set
r kelly recently fired two of his
attorneys in the weeks leading up to the
trial
the newly hired defense team for the
singer asked the judge to delay this
upcoming trial
so that they can be properly prepared
for the case the r
b singer faces federal sex trafficking
charges and has been in the spotlight
for sexual abuse allegations
dating back more than two decades
still ahead on law and crime daily the
rescue a six-year-old girl
from kidnapping that's capturing all the
all of our hearts
but first vultures coyotes and insects
an
expert in bones takes a stand for mark
redwine's defense
in the murder of his 13 year old son
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back the state rests case in the
trial of mark redwine in california
and the defense begins its case with an
expert in bones
lawn crimes angenette levy is here with
what the expert
had to say and jeanette yeah brian the
defense has been arguing throughout this
trial that the damage to dylan redwine's
skull was likely caused by an animal
and maybe a person but definitely not
mark redwine
by the time dylan redwine's remains had
been discovered in 2013
he'd been missing for seven months all
that was left was bones
dylan's skull wasn't found until 2015
and it was damaged
defense forensic pathologist dr bruce
anderson gave his opinion
this is quite consistent with
post-mortem breakage
animal scavenge dylan was on a
court-ordered visit with his dad in
november 2012 when he went missing
diagrams show where his bones and
belongings were found
his skull found a distance from his
other bones
there's really only two ways for that to
happen a person picks up the bones and
takes it
or a coyote or a canid picks up the
bones and take it
and i think it's probably more likely
it's the animal and that's not the
person
the prosecution has said mark redwine
moved his son's head
and some marks were caused by a knife on
the skull
dr anderson said those were alterations
not
cuts on cross-examination prosecutors
questioned dr
anderson's claims you would agree
this is a question as to how dylan
redwine was actually killed
and ended up where he did i certainly
can't bring anything to bear on that
dr anderson testified he didn't use a
microscope with as high a magnification
level as he usually would when examining
dylan's remains
would you agree with me that you
couldn't determine whether a tool had
caused it
uh yes i'll i'll agree to that and he
became angry
when asked about the condition of
dylan's clothing and personal items
found on middle mountain road
i don't have any idea what animals do
with backpacks
now dr anderson was actually caught on a
hot mic
after the court took a break telling the
defense attorney that he would not let
the prosecutor get under his skin again
so he was going to kind of reign it in
since he
lost his temper under cross-examination
he also said with regard
on redirect to that whole issue about
using a higher powered microscope he
said that
if he didn't feel he could have
completed the examination thoroughly he
would have sought
a higher power higher powered microscope
instead of the tool that he did use
brian thanks angela let's bring back
former federal prosecutor
nima romani and terry austin to break
down the defense's witness
terry vultures coyotes and insects the
defense expert gave reasons for
so many different injuries do you think
it raised any reasonable doubt
well i think it raised some reasonable
doubt but i think this is a very smart
jury they've been asking questions all
along and they asked
some very poignant questions here they
wanted to know whether the marks
that this witness dr bruce anderson saw
on the skull was that natural
was it caused by scavengers or was it
caused by some sort of instrument so i
thought
they honed in right on the important
part here and frankly i don't think
as the defense's first witness he made a
very good impression as angenette said
he was
arrogant he lost his cool and i think
the jury is recognizing this
and i think they're going to overall
discount his testimony
no nema could that let's call a bit of a
personality defect losing your cool and
some of the points that the prosecution
raised could that be a reason why this
was
picked apart by the by the prosecution
in terms of what this expert put on at
the record
brian again i agree with terry on this
one you know dr anderson got rattled
this is the defense's star witness their
whole theory of the case was that dylan
walked out
in the 12 13 year old and you know was
attacked by animals and there's so much
evidence in this case that favors the
state you got the blood
in the house and the vehicle you got the
cadaver dog alerting you got this really
strange
relationship between father and son so
and the fact that the
body was dismembered and miles apart
all that is really bad for the defense
so they really needed to come out the
gate with a very strong witness that was
going to support the theory
that this was a wild animal attack and i
don't think dr anderson did that
unfortunately
for the defense absolutely not and
jeanette dr anderson practices in
arizona typically
how long had it been since he's dealt
with a case in colorado
he said it had actually been 32 years so
it had been quite a bit of time
he's used to examining the bodies he
said or the remains the bones really
of people who crossed the border
illegally and
maybe died in the desert so that's what
he's used to dealing with
so it had been some time since he had
dealt with an
issue involving a set of bones in
colorado where the topography is much
different
interesting cases continuing to go on
make sure to check out the law and crime
network for gavel to gavel coverage
on the mark redwine trial coming up on
law and crime daily
reenacted testimony from accused
murderer robert durst
plus how 30 minutes could change a life
the abduction and rescue of a little
girl
the police body cam video you don't want
to miss next
[Music]
welcome back a six-year-old girl in
kentucky is now safe from a kidnapping
attempt
thanks to the quick thinking of an
eyewitness and two police officers
body camera video from a louisville cop
shows the officers rushing to the scene
a witness called 9-1-1 with a partial
license plate number
and detailed description less than 30
minutes later they found the girl
one of the officers opened the passenger
side door carrying her away from the
suspect
the officer taking 40-year-old robbie
wilt into custody
records show wilt later told the
officers that he saw the girl playing
near the street
circled the block then took her stay on
the ground
he reportedly went on to say the girl
was crying and he realized
what he did was wrong so he began to
drive back as police arrived
he appears to have no relation to the
victim he's charged with kidnapping a
minor and is being held on one million
dollars bond
back with us a breakdown this heroic
rescue is former federal prosecutor nima
romani and co-host terry austin
terry your thoughts on how ever how
everyday people helped
an officer's rescue of this young girl
you know we don't hear about these good
stories
enough and i think it's wonderful that
not only did we have the police
responding so
quickly but we had these bystanders who
not only made the 9-1-1
call but they were smart enough to get
the license plate so kudos to everyone
all around thank goodness this was
thought it
nema everyone home safe and sound the
officers got their person the
six-year-old girl at home your reaction
to the officers quick thinking and
jumping into action
outstanding work by these police
officers and you know as attorneys we're
in the business of misery so we're often
hearing about
cases that have gone bad you know
kidnapping murder those types of things
so
the fact that the officers quick
thinking and those
bystanders good for them for getting
involved and this
young child six-year-old is safe at home
we gotta give credit where credit is due
and this is a great story heading into
the weekend
absolutely wishing all the best of that
little girl and her family hopefully
she's home safe
and sound with those who love her when
we come back the galveston
trial reenactment continues in
california versus robert durst
testimony from the real estate air about
dismembering his neighbor
and the fear he felt when he knew he
would be discovered
[Music]
welcome back the robert durst murder
trial is continuing with
previous testimony from when the real
estate heir was accused of murdering his
neighbor
morris black robert durst is currently
facing murder charges relating to his
best friend susan berman
who was shot execution style in december
two thousand
he was previously on trial for the
murder and dismemberment of morris black
his neighbor in galveston texas durst
was later acquitted of murder
by claiming self-defense transcripts
from that trial are now being reenacted
by attorneys and law students
some of the most shocking
cross-examination of durs describing
cutting up
black's body tom morris black's head off
his torso
yes sir did you look with great detail
at the pictures that showed the sawtooth
marks on the bones
each and every one of his limbs
not with great detail no sir
no did you do this cut up before you had
the fifth of jack daniels or after you
had the fifth
jack daniels after i had the fifth of
jack daniels
you drank the whole fifth and then
started cutting
almost all the fifth yes sir
the testimony continued including how he
put his neighbor's body parts in garbage
bags
and dumped them in the calvinson bay he
admits that he panicked when he returned
to the bay
and saw the bags floating
you agree you wanted those bags to sink
and not be found right
yes sir when you came back sunday and
you saw them floating
you panicked didn't you yes sir and they
were
and the reality then was you were about
to be discovered weren't you mr durst
by late when i saw the police there
i knew i had been discovered you knew
that morris black was going to be
identified did you not
yes sir you fully expected that right
well when i saw the police had found
everything yes sir
maybe i said hi just killed this man in
your apartment
and you look up and you wave and you say
hi
i did not kill morris black i
did what i did all right nemo let's make
you the defense attorney for
just a minute is there an argument that
could help durst against this testimony
or is it best to just ignore it and
focus elsewhere
brian i know why the prosecution is
doing this john lewin
wants to plant that seed in the juror's
mind that even though he got off
with that houston jury that this is a
murderer this isn't a
old man who's in frail health he's
capable of
killing someone and chopping up the body
but this may backfire because this is
already a very long trial and these
jurors were expecting four to five
months it's going to go longer because
of medical issues
with respect to durst that have delayed
and we've had some dark days
judge windham is allowing everything in
parts of the jinx maybe the whole jinx
as well as all good things a fictional
movie so
this trial is really dragging on and i
can see the defense arguing hey we've
already tried this we've litigated it
he's been exonerated
you're wasting our time prosecution so
this could potentially backfire
but i don't see any other way for the
state to do this because this was their
strongest
case with respect to the evidence
related to this murder even though it
resulted in an acquittal
yeah john lewin is definitely throwing
everything in and the kitchen sink your
kitchen sink my kitchen sink and terry's
but we'll see how the jury can
deliberate with this
terry at the very least this testing
when he proves what durst is capable of
but how does it prove that he killed
berman
well it doesn't but i think what lewin
is trying to do here is to show
that if durst is capable of actually
chopping up someone's body he needed to
take a fifth to drink
and go ahead and continue that didn't
really bother him that much
but if he's able to do that then he is
also
able to shoot his best friend susan
berman in the back of the head
execution style so i understand why the
prosecution
is really trying to tie all these cases
together i
agree with nema you want to make sure
that the motive is there
and that the jury understands he's
connected to the disappearance of kathy
he's connected to morris black and
obviously
now susan berman and it's all together
but the fact that he
is spending so much time is wasting the
jury's time and i do think they will
ultimately hold it against him and i
don't think that
all of this detail particularly in the
moore's black case
is going to you know help the case at
all so i would stop
yeah we'll see how this plays out thank
you both and thank you for joining us
here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you